c'est ce qu'il me reste de Chamia
le 24 juillet la vie de Magda a basculé
sa fille chaymagamale présentatrice
télévisée de 42 ans était assassinés par
son mari un célèbre juge de la capitale
à l'issue d'un procès médiatisé début
septembre l'homme et son complice ont
été condamnés à la peine de mort la mère
de Chaima ne comprend toujours pas
7 ans de mariage et ce traître la tue de
la pire des façons
on ne parle pas d'un quelconque ignorant
de quelqu'un qui n'aurait pas reçu
l'éducation là non
c'est un homme très puissant que l'on
pensait au-dessus de tout soupçon
quelques jours avant sa mort Chaima
Gamal publié sur les réseaux sociaux
cette vidéo
[Applaudissements]
selon un rapport des Nations Unies paru
en 2015 plus de 5 millions d'égyptiennes
seraient victimes de violences
conjugales chaque année il n'existe
pourtant que peu de structures pour les
accueillir
dans cette ONG assistante sociale et
juriste sont formés pour venir en aide
aux victimes l'association a reçu près
de 600 femmes cette année un chiffre en
constante augmentation
nous recevons des femmes victimes de
violences physiques et dans de nombreux
cas le mari est au chômage et se drogue
il force alors sa femme à travailler et
prend l'ensemble de son salaire beaucoup
de ces femmes ne sont pas préparées au
marché du travail et se retrouvent dans
des lieux dangereux où elles sont
harcelées parfois victimes de violences
sexuelles elles sont exploitées avec des
horaires de travail très important et
des salaires de misère
les victimes bien souvent préfèrent
rester silencieuses
j'ai attendu près de trois ans avant de
divorcer je craignais le jugement de la
société en tant que femme divorcée la
manière dont j'allais être perçue dans
les sociétés orientales beaucoup de gens
pensent qu'une femme divorcée ne peut
pas sortir seule il vous regarde mal
vraiment
cette stigmatisation n'est pas nouvelle
à la fin des années 90 le président
Mubarak lui-même s'emparait du problème
et y apporter une réponse surprenante un
village entièrement dédié aux femmes
veuvées divorcer après le décès de son
père il y a 20 ans nermanaghi et sa mère
étaient parmi les premières arrivées au
village depuis nerma vit dans des
conditions modestes
l'eau n'est pas potable on reçoit des
gericanes là dehors
quand on est arrivé il n'y avait pas
d'eau pas d'électricité ou même de gens
aujourd'hui grâce à Dieu ça va
bien mieux qu'au début en tout cas
faute d'infrastructures cependant la
grande majorité des femmes divorcées
sont reparties dans leur village natale
laissant derrière elle des dizaines
d'habitations abandonnées certaines ont
été revendus sa belle use et son mari
ont racheté cette maison il y a 10 ans
les femmes divorcées sont venues sont
restés un peu puis tout le monde est
reparti chez soi alors on est beaucoup à
en avoir profité pour racheter ces
terrains
mais on a de gros problèmes
d'inondations il y a des maisons dans
lesquelles l'eau sort du sol fait le
baie
les femmes égyptiennes confrontaient à
une société encore profondément
conservatrice peine encore aujourd'hui à
faire respecter leurs droits mais grâce
aux réseaux sociaux leur voix se font
désormais entendre à l'été 2020 la
vaguemi tout défaire le sur l'Égypte
[Musique]
l'année suivante le gouvernement
transforme le délit de harcèlement en
crime puni de peine plus lourdes un
changement législatif salué par le nu à
l'époque la presse égyptienne est même
se fait désormais l'écho des affaires de
violence faite aux femmes Nadia Mabrouk
avait trois ans lorsque ses ongles ont
fait éruption chez elle pour tuer sa
mère de 8 balles de fusil son tort avoir
épousé un bédouin originaire d'une autre
tribu que la sienne début septembre la
jeune journaliste a publié un article où
elle raconte pour la première fois ce
crime d'honneur j'avais besoin d'écrire
cet article besoin de parler
car je me suis tue pendant beaucoup trop
longtemps je veux m'excuser auprès de ma
mère
car j'ai passé 32 ans à avoir peur de
parler d'elle
il y a même eu des moments pendant
toutes ces années où je l'ai jugé
où j'ai cru que tout était de sa faute
la parole se libère et le combat
féministe s'amplifie fin mars un groupe
de femmes parlementaire a déposé un
projet de loi contre les violences
faites aux femmes le texte prévoit
notamment l'interdiction du mariage des
mineurs et des peines de prison pour les
auteurs de violences conjugales
si le chemin vers la liberté semble
encore long les Égyptiennes sont en tout
cas décidé à en prendre la route
[Musique]